Facebook is making big changes in how
you see political ads on the site the
social media giant came under fire for
its lack of transparency after Russians
allegedly used Facebook ads to meddle in
the 2016 presidential election well now
all political ads on facebook and its
subsidiary Instagram will be labeled
that way clicking on the label will show
who paid for the ad users can flag any
other content they think should be
included you can also see an archive of
ads plus details on their budgets who
financed them and how many views they
got Carolyn Everson's is Facebook's vice
president of global marketing solutions
Caroline good to see you thanks for
having me yes good to have you here so
tell us what this new policy requires
advertisers to do one of the things that
we heard from our community is they want
to understand the ads that they are
receiving who are they from who was
trying to influence them and so the
political ad Transparency work that
we're doing is now gonna give people all
across the United States a real
understanding of who paid for the ad and
then if they want to go and get further
information they'll understand who
actually received the ad who were
reached the age the gender and the
location and how much was spent right in
other words in order to place an ad you
have to have a u.s. ID an address a
social security number all of that
however we knew in the last elections
the Russians used an American entity to
to place their ad so how would it
prevent a foreign entity from
influencing our elections we're doing
everything we can to ensure the
integrity of elections especially ahead
of the midterm elections so this is one
very critical step to go through
verification process but it's not the
only step we are using technology with
machine learning as well as people to
evaluate whether or not those ads are
legitimate and we're also asking people
on Facebook to report ads so you can
click on the right hand side of any ad
on Facebook and you can tell us a lot of
things actually you can say if you never
want to receive an ad from that
advertiser again but you also can tell
us if you think this is a political ad
that should have been labeled how much
do you think people will engage with
this because sometimes and we've seen
certainly with social media people like
to reinforce their existing views of
things and then pass that along to other
people so how much do you think people
will actually look
to see who's behind the ad and really go
down that Lane we think people genuinely
want to understand who is trying to
influence them we also are going to make
an API available so news broadcasters
and third-party watchdogs can also look
out for whether or not someone's trying
to influence both political or issue ads
we remind people what an API is yes so
that allows people from a technology
standpoint so a third-party group to
access the information in a very
seamless way so they can watch to see
who is actually running those ads and
give us feedback so access the
information behind the ad to know who's
behind it so forth yes we think it's
incredibly important that people have
full transparency by the way not just
with political and issue ads we're
taking a broader view so that people can
see who are running ads across all
different types of categories not just
political and issue ads well Carolyn
this sounds all very good now but you
know Facebook has gone through some
dicey times Mark Zuckerberg was on
Capitol Hill did a major mayor copal
because people thought what took you
guys so long to make the changes I would
imagine you can't go through something
like this and not have a moment of
self-reflection within the company this
has been an incredibly important moment
for Facebook I've been at Facebook for
seven years and I think this is probably
the biggest cultural shift that I have
seen being led by mark but the entire
company understands the enormous
responsibility we have to protect
people's privacy to reduce the spread of
fake news and to ensure the integrity of
our elections and the entire company is
focused we're adding over 10,000 people
we're using technology to help us find
bad actors and bad behavior we have a
huge responsibility to over 2 billion
people and I think it's a real
understanding of that responsibility and
a commitment of resources you never
really control the privacy though that's
what I wonder can it can you ever really
do that one of the things that we are
very focused on is giving consumers full
control over their experience on
Facebook as a matter of fact in Europe
today there is a new data law that
rolled out called GDP our general data
protection regulation and what it
essentially is doing and we're rolling
it out here in the United States and
around the world is giving consumers
full control over their experience you
can tell us whether or not you want ads
to be
you can determine whether or not you
want us to use facial recognition and
your to Facebook is voluntarily putting
in place GDP our here in the United
States yes we are rolling out we're
calling it the global privacy experience
because GDP our isn't really relevant
for people here in the United States in
terms of terminology but yes the same
controls that are being made available
in Europe are rolling out globally we
want consumers to feel completely in
control of their Facebook experience if
they do not want targeted ads they do
not have to have them you have entertain
- if you don't want the targeted ads you
have to move remove your own political
preference on Facebook there are we are
giving people information around their
political affiliation their religion as
well as their relationship status and
they can remove that information if they
don't want that to be utilized and
targeted ads all right Carolyn Everson
thank you so much for coming in thank
you so much for having me I really
appreciate it